[موسيقى]
مو جزء الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله استدعت الخارجيه الاردنيه سفير
اسرائيل في عمان بعد تصريحات لوزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
عن عدم وجود شعب الفلسطيني واستخدامه
خارطه لاسرائيل تضم الاردن ولا راضيه
الفلسطينيه
ووصفت الخارجيه الاردنيه استخدام الخريطه
بالتصرف العنصري والتحريضي الارعن من
جانبه قال رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس
اسماعيل هنيه ان تصريحات
الاردن تكشف العقيده السياسيه للكيان
الاسرائيلي
وقد دعت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لاعتقال ادنى رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد رشديه تصريحاته
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي اكد انها دليل
قاطع على الفكر العنصري المتطرف الذي يحكم
اطراف الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
واقل مفوض السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي بشان عدم وجود شعب فلسطيني غير
مقبوله ومرفوضه تماما وانها تزيد من
التوتر في المنطقه
قال الرئيس
دراسه الاقتراحات الصينيه لتسويه الازمه
الاوكرانيه وبانها تعتزم بحثها واكد بوزن
خلال اللقاء ان جمعه بناظره الصيني عن
روسيا منفتحه على عمليه التفاوض دائما
من جانبه على ان الرئيس الصيني ان الصين
وروسيا شركتان في التعاون الاستراتيجي
الشامل اضاف ان بلا داوود تولي اهتماما
كبيرا لتطوير العلاقات بين البلدين
وقد دعا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
العالم لعدم الانخداع باي تحرك تكتيكي من
جانب روسيا بدعم من الصين لوقف الحرب
بشروطها الخاصه
اقرا الاتحاد الاوروبي وتخصيصا ملياري
يورو لدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا وتعاهد وزراء
وخارجيه للاتحاد خلال اجتماعهم في بروكسل
بتسليمه من الاسلحه والذخائر في اواخر ما
يؤير المقبل كما اعلنا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن عن مساعده عسكريه
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 350 مليون دولار
قال ملك شركه فاجنر يفكي قوته تسيطر على
سبعين في المئه من مدينه بخموت واكد ان
مقاتلي فاجناني العمليات الهجوميه للسلاء
على المدينه في الاثناء اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان الدفاع الجوي الروسي
رصد في يوم العشرين من مارس قاذفتين
استراتيجيتين امريكيتين من طرازيل
تحلقان باتجاه الحدود الروسيه فوق بحر
البلطيق
قال جوزيف بوريلم مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي ان الوضع في تونس سيء
للغايه اقتصاديا وسياسيا اضف بوريلا ان
وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد سيناقشونه ما سماها
تصريحات غير المقبوله تجاه جنسيه افريقيه
التي صدرت عن الرئيس التونسي
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مع احتفال
التونسيين بمرور اكثر من 12 عاما على
ثورتهم تظل الولايات المتحده ملتزمه
بالحريات الاساسيه والمؤسسات الديمقراطيه
والحوار السياسي الشامل اكد بلنكن وقوف
بلاده الى جانب التونسيين وهم يواجهون
تحديات اقتصاديه مستمره بحسب تعبيره في
المقابل قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان
بلاده لن تقبل اي تدخل خارجي في شؤونها
مره اخرى واضاف سعيد خلال زيارته الى
ولايه القيروان ان تونس لن تفرط في
سيادتها لاحد لانها ليست تحت الحمايه ولا
الانتداب وفق تعبيره
اشكركم على متابعه الموجه زي ما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]